[Music]  Miley Cyrus and a dolly parton  absolutely crushed Jolin alongside  pentatonix on Tuesday nights  the boys have always said no matter what  you think of Molly she is so talented  and she is so natural after the show  Miley took to Instagram to say thanks to  her so called a fairy godmother quote  love my fairy godmother Dolly Parton and  sending protective energy to the ever so  sacred Dollywood and all the homes folks  in Tennessee who are experiencing this  devastating fire guests have been  evacuated from the area surrounding  Dolly's iconic amusement park this week  as wildfires rage on in the Great Smoky  Mountains now dolly wasn't Miley's only  special guest at the voice Tuesday the  star also brought along her grandma who  she calls mammy Miley captioned to this  - cute pic mammy is captain of the team  Miley cheer squad so I'm really excited  to win the voice